Так.
Quantum circuit — це одиниця цінності
для твого бізнесу, qubit — одиниця інформації,
а circuit — одиниця обчислення.
Тож спробуємо розібратися, що таке quantum circuit,
і розглянемо його структуру.
Ось як виглядає quantum circuit:
він складається з частин — qubits
зображено горизонтальними лініями, і в цьому прикладі ми показуємо
circuit, що має чотири qubits, які ти бачиш
тут. Тепер — gates:
саме ними ми керуємо qubits.
Gates читаються зліва направо,
і однокубітні gates можуть бути одно-
або багатокубітними gates.
Бачиш там controlled gate —
той, що має лінію між двома qubits?
Саме там відбувається операція заплутування.
І нарешті — вимірювання та класичний вивід.
Дуже важливо: circuit запускають багато разів,
щоб отримати результат — це поняття shots.
Лічильник shots — це кількість разів,
яку потрібно повторити обчислення, щоб отримати результат.
Ну,
як вони виглядають?
Подивимося, як виглядає двокубітний —
це була та картинка раніше, правда, де вводили зсув фази,
і я показував операцію, яка виконує це обертання,
що дозволяє виконати операцію інтерференції.
Тож порівняємо класичний circuit
і quantum circuit. У класичному circuit
ти не побачиш синіх місяців, правда?
Тут немає обертань, усе рожеве,
і ти бачиш лише окремі стани.
У цих gates видно лише вікна станів,
але подивися, яким буде контраст,
коли ми справді реалізуємо quantum circuit.
Це реальні circuits, що ми запускаємо на наших квантових комп'ютерах,
і ти теж можеш їх спробувати.
Circuits, які ми будемо створювати
за допомогою комбінації gates,
генерують повну складну амплітуду —
ту картину, яку я показував.
Чому це важливо?
Тому що ми тепер можемо генерувати ці складні зв'язки
між qubits у термінах фаз
та заплутування, і через акт вимірювання
ми можемо колапсувати цей величезний обсяг
обчислень, що відбуваються всередині, —
до якоїсь важливої відповіді.
Ось як ми зрештою приходимо
до відповіді. Поставивши їх поруч, просто візуально
можна відчути, що класичний circuit ніколи
не зможе задіяти той величезний обчислювальний простір,
який доступний quantum circuit.
Ці приклади дають тобі інтуїцію
щодо багатства, з яким ми можемо отримати доступ до цього великого простору станів.
І прекрасне в цьому те, що ми можемо
мати багато класів circuits для
різних функцій. Тож,
наприклад, цей circuit
призначений для моделювання фінансових ризиків.
Ось приклад circuit,
що використовується для пошуку та оптимізації задач.
А ось приклад circuit, що використовується для
симуляції молекули. Важливий
висновок: ти можеш проектувати різні circuits
для різних застосувань.
Circuits, які ми проектуємо, потім фіксуються
в програмному забезпеченні та зберігаються як ПЗ,
і у нашому випадку ми зберігаємо їх у Qiskit —
нашому відкритому SDK для квантових обчислень.
Це один із найбільш широко використовуваних
програмних фреймворків для квантових обчислень.
І можеш уявити, як будуєш
бібліотеки circuits, що вбудовуються в
класичні програми, які тепер поєднують найкраще з класичного програмування
і найкраще з квантових можливостей.